documenting hurricanes Katrina and Rita
at seven-thirty at 9pm it's afterwards
author Robert Bloch is interviewed by
former FEMA director James Lee width
added 10 another chance to see authors
and photographers taking questions from
New Orleans residents that's 12 hours of
book TV this sunday beginning at noon
eastern on c-span 2 Steven Freeman and
Joel blythers consider voter suppression
and fraud in her new book was the 2004
presidential election stolen next
they're joined by Michigan
representative John Conyers junior at
politics and prose bookstore in
Washington DC this is about an hour 10
minutes good evening
so we're just about to get started we
are going to begin with one of our
authors and then sort of you know add
them in kind of have a three-course meal
for you this evening I'd like to first
off welcome you all out this evening and
thank you for forwarding your various
neighborhoods and coming in it's been a
amazing couple of days as far as the
weather goes my name is Michael income
the general manager here at politics and
prose and on behalf of the two owners
and all of the staff here it's my
pleasure to welcome you out to tonight's
event stephen freeman teaches research
methods and survey design at the
university of pennsylvania he's
currently in a taxi on his way up
Connecticut Avenue oh no he's right here
in Amman dr. Freeman has received
national awards for his research and
launched one of the very first attempts
to examine the validity of the 2004
presidential elections Joel Bly fith
seated to my immediate right is the
editor of in these times magazine
available at politics and Bruce and has
written extensively for publications
including the New York Times and the
Philadelphia Inquirer divot together
they have written was the 2004
presidential election stolen an amazing
search for approximately 8 million votes
that would have determined the outcome
of the election a number of people have
asked me when they found out that I was
going to host this event why they're
still talking about it and without
hopefully pulling any of tonight's
author's thunder I thought about the
previous election of two thousand and
how remarkably unsatisfying the progress
made in places like Florida had been
during the election of 2004 I thought
about how each one of Bush's victories
seemed like they were one under the
rules of television tag or some other
playground game and I finally I was
reminded of a lakers playoff game a
couple years ago where Devin George hit
the winning shot and then immediately
ran off the court
the reason being was according to old
NBA rules if the team had already left
the arena the outcome could not be
reversed we're we hopefully will also be
joined by the distinguished
representative from the 14th
Congressional District of Michigan
representative John Conyers who wrote
the introduction to this book just wait
until he shows up then walk lab but if
he does a representative John Conyers is
currently serving his 20th term in the
United States House of Representatives
where he is working on all the major
issues of our time including a rock
racial profiling education Social
Security reparations and last but not
least election reform so without further
ado it's my pleasure to turn it over
first to even Freeman welcome that's a
real pleasure to be here thanks for the
applause it's nice to nice to get some
friendly faces after dealing with all
this torrential thunderstorms for the
last few hours I got involved with this
just raise this up a little bit yeah I
can't I'm sort of accidentally okay sort
of accidentally involved in all this i
was actually teaching a course and in
survey methods at the time of the 2004
election and was taken aback by the by
the exit polls in just how how they
could be so far off the mean for people
who are not familiar with it exit polls
are very different than than a than a
pre-election telephone pole I mean it's
they don't have any of the issues about
who's going to turn up or will people
change their minds it's it's I liking it
more to instead of trying to predict the
weather a few days in advance just
placing placing beakers somewhere and
accurately measuring rainfall or
snowfall
it should be really a fairly accurate
predictor of what had happened on
Election Day so you know it's taken
aback that day that it was so far off
expecting to hear some explanation but
rather than any explanations coming
forth there it just seemed to have
disappeared I went the next day to CNN
website and there was no record of this
this exit poll discrepancy and started
to look at it I mean at first I was not
particularly I didn't think it was
likely that you know how could 10
million votes be be stolen one of the
Democrats be saying something when in
somebody be reporting on it one of the
people in the rep in the relevant
academic fields be writing about it but
in fact as I looked into it there were
very few explanations coming forward
about any kind of possible polling error
and meanwhile as I looked into it I was
just astounded day after day looking
into this at all the vulnerabilities and
and and problems with our election
system so so anyway that was that was my
initial foray into all this and and it
just you know aside from any any kind of
concerns and outrage as a citizen it was
just really quite a remarkable thing
intellectually how this could be coming
to pass I was I was really you know I
wouldn't say I'm I thought of myself as
being fairly cynical and and worldly but
I was like I say and for a shock a shock
an hour as I was researching this
basically and what are some of those
shocks I mean first and foremost we see
an electronic voting system that it's
just it's just absolutely incredible
that this could be happening in this
country you know I read a story recently
I don't know if you're familiar with the
book of fine balance about about India
life in India and there's a sequence in
there about voting and how you know one
of the lower caste groups how they go
and vote in there they're told by the
one of the Brahmins how you know they're
going to they're going to write their
vote for them don't worry and you know
most of them are illiterate they can't
do it one person tries to stand up and
say no I'll write my own boat in and he
him and his family their house is burnt
down with them in it and you know
obviously we see that and we say we
don't trust this Brahmin to write our
vote down for us but in fact that's
exactly what we're doing now not not
exactly because they have to do with one
vote at a time what we've done is we've
entrusted programmers to they can
basically program anything it's almost a
trivial matter for a programmer to write
two lines of code in a system that says
on November second at 7am convert ten
percent of all votes from column B 2
column a at 9pm on November second 2004
race this line in the line before it and
that's it we have no record of healthy
how votes were cast and it's changed
that simple and instead of having to do
with one vote at a time like they're
doing it in India he could do millions
of votes this way thirty-five percent of
americans voted on these systems in 2004
that numbers gone up considerably for
2006 okay that's one set of shocks
another is well as familiar with florida
but but that you know i want to thank
you for for talking a little bit about
why we're still talking about this in
two thousand you might have expected
that those those um errors or mistakes
or anomalies might have been corrected
but in fact what happened is people
looked at to two thousand and ken
blackwell when he was asked is he
concerned that ohio 2004 might be the
Florida two thousand he said well I'm
looking at Katherine Harris she's not in
a soup line she's in Congress now so
those were the lessons that were learned
from 2000 and looking at Ohio I mean
this is just shocking one thing after
another in that state and and people ask
how can this happen without anybody
detecting it
that questions an absurdity it's been
detected it's been detected time and
time again in Ohio there's you know just
just a few of the things shocking to see
or you know during the non recount I
mean they were supposed to they were
supposed to look at some of the look at
precincts three percent of precincts
determine whether or not the count
matched the official count matched what
the manual count read but but that just
didn't get done they didn't select the
precincts randomly and even the
precincts that they did select were the
the people who were supposed to be
matching them up they were looking at
she cheats to to determine so as to come
up with the same account that was
reported on Election Day anyway in some
of these counties Clermont County for
example there were affidavits filed by
people who were who were participating
in it that carries ovals were covered up
with stickers there were no stickers in
use on election day it's it's not it's
not an accepted thing on the on the
survey so they actually found these
things and nothing nothing at come of it
so anyway we have these we have these
problems and and then the exit polls
what the exit polls showed where was a
discrepancy nationwide on the order of
10 million votes in Ohio it was what we
focused on in the book would I focused
on in most of my analyses is a
particular statistic called within
precinct just what we call it within
precinct disparity that's a difference
between how voters said they voted and
the official counts in those same
precincts nationwide depending on how
you look at it it's about a seven
percentage point disparity between how
people said they voted and in those same
precincts the official count in Ohio it
was about 11 percentage points
differential now there are some problems
with the exit polls that we can't say
for certain maybe Bush voters didn't
respond the official account is that
Bush voters didn't respond or didn't
participate in the polls of the same
rate it's Carrie voters now we we
studied that very closely and for a lot
of reasons that explanation doesn't seem
to hold up where bush voters
predominated in fact response rates were
higher in other evidence indicates Bush
risk voters were responding at if
anything higher rates than Carrie voters
meanwhile there's a whole lot of
correlations in the data that are
unexplainable by polling error for
example the disparities higher where
their Republican governors the
disparities higher where there were high
amounts of complaints on Election Day
asperities higher where there are more
african-american voters and so on and so
forth we only have state-level data I
mean that's it that's a whole nother
issue is the lack of transparency in me
in the voting system is matched by a
lack of transparency in the exit polls
these were conducted by a Media
Consortium but they've never been
released to any independent researchers
so we're working indirectly through
state-level data but anyway from what we
can see in Ohio for example the one stay
where there's been an investigation
those numbers seem to match up there
seems plenty of reason why plenty of
votes that are lost changed or switched
that would account for this sharp
disparity so anyway that's those are
some of the the key points in the book
hopefully you're properly disturbed and
I'll let y'all disturb you a little
further
hey well it's great to be here I'm going
to I've sort of abridged the conclusion
of our book which sort of raises some of
the points that I think so the
overarching themes or overarching
concerns we have and so I'm going to
read this and bear with me I think it's
it's an important message exit polls can
provide a wealth of information when
they are analyzed in an informed way
they are a vital tool to ensure election
integrity the best use of the exit polls
is not to oppose to replace the official
count but rather to serve as an alarm
system to ensure democratic process it
may turn out to be the case that the
most accurate count in the 2004
presidential election was the exit poll
result but the point isn't to have to
choose now between the exit poll result
in the official count when exit polls
contradict rather than confirm the
official count other parts of the
machinery of democracy need to be
activated including the freed press
which has the skills and responsibility
to investigate and nonpartisan
government bodies which through an
entirely different array of methods also
have the skills in a civic mandate to
investigate our investigations led us to
conclude that we have little reason to
trust the official results of the 2004
u.s. presidential election few
jurisdictions provided compelling
verification that votes were counted as
cast sixty-four percent of americans
voted on either direct recorded
electronic voting machines or optical
scan systems both of which are to
varying degrees vulnerable to
interference through hacking or
programming fraud in most cases
americans are being asked in effect to
pay less our absolute trust in voting
machine corporations that have failed to
meet minimal expectations of
impartiality honesty freedom from
conflict of interest and transparency
why haven't the companies that produce
electronic voting machines made them so
that they provide an audit trail which
is easily achieved through paper records
and why haven't they allowed government
regulators to inspect their software the
answers to both of these questions is
that no one has effectively demanded
that they do so as is the case in any
system where their incentives to cheat
must be conducted to keep voting machine
companies and office holders honest in
Ohio the Green Party paid for a recount
of Ohio ballots but rather than recount
in accordance talk Ohio law the county's
choose a random sample of three percent
of the total votes cast Secretary of
State Kenneth Blackwell interpreted
random to meet sample of the counties
choosing as the american statistical
association president fritz sure and put
it this is quote analogous IRS agents
allowing taxpayers to choose for
themselves the items on their tax
returns to be audited unquote none of
the explanations given this far
explained by the official count differed
so dramatically from the exit poll
results the discrepancy must be
investigated impartially and by
institutions that can be trusted to cut
ducked such investigations there is
still hope new legislation has been
proposed and important lawsuits and
legal actions are underweight the most
significant proposed national
legislation is representative rush holds
Democrat New Jersey's voter confidence
and increased accessibility Act bill HR
5 50 which would require the use of
voter verified paper records and audits
and recounts HR 550 would also prohibit
the use of undisclosed software and
wireless communication devices in voting
systems because elections are
administered by the states rather than
the federal government most of these
most significant developments are at the
state level with closely watched reforms
proposed in California New Mexico and
critical swing states such as Ohio
Pennsylvania and Florida finally d
re-direct recorded electronic voting
machines themselves continue to be
scrutinized even as one of the major
vendors diebold faces securities law
suit and rumors that it may discontinue
its voting machine division in Leon
County Florida the supervises visor of
Elections aeon sancho authorized a test
of his diebold voting system to see if
election results could be altered using
only a memory card ha rehearsed e a
computer programmer from Finland
facilitated a test in which voters voted
on a touchscreen machine and also
recorded their vote separately by using
a doctored memory card Hearst II was
able to produce results completely
different from what the voters in
ended when following the test diebold
and other voting machine vendors refused
to sell new voting machines to Leon
County voting rights groups across the
country wrote Florida officials and
supported sancho Americans should not
have to presume a fair count the
mainstream media has to all infects and
purposes established to borrow a phrase
from Joseph Heller a catch-22 for
election investigation no investigation
without proof but then what proof can be
had without an investigation the
American public has the right to be
skeptical about whether there was a fair
count in the last presidential election
and to have their skepticism proven
wrong by overwhelming evidence in any
functioning democracy this test would
consistently be met without stirring
controversy absence of scrutiny does not
make a democracy function democratic
processes do in the case of the 2004
presidential election the absence of
reporting on the election controversy
has left the public highly suspicious
azog be interactive online poll one
month after the election revealed that
twenty eight point five percent of
respondents thought that questions about
the accuracy of the official account
were very valid and another fourteen
percent thought that concerns were quote
somewhat valid end quote in other words
forty-two percent of all Americans had
immediate concerns about what happened
on November second 2004 during his
recent confirmation hearing Supreme
Court Justice John Roberts was forced to
acknowledge that the right to vote is
quote preservative of all other rights
unquote without the power to elect our
representatives and especially to vote
out of office those who misuse power
ultimately we have no rights at our all
in his recent book the battle to for
Florida Lance DeHaven Smith who's a
professor of public policy at Florida
State University writes quote as an
expert on Florida government and policy
I had been aware the Florida election
laws were being undermined and subverted
by the very people who were responsible
for assuring their proper execution end
quote however he says he was not too
upset by this because he expected the
dispute over Florida two thousand
elections to lead to reforms in the
electoral process similar to those that
arose after the flawed presidential
elections of eighteen hundred and
eighteen seventy six he writes quote
but alarm me was not the malfeasance and
misfeasance of high officials but rather
the inability of both the media and the
public to conduct a post-mortem of the
investigation fiasco determine who was
responsible for the electoral breakdown
hold officials accountable for any
crimes and enact constitutional and
statutory reforms as necessary to root
out corruption and to correct flaws in
the system and quote he goes on to note
that the United States appears to be
following the path of ancient Rome and
Greece referring to the two great
democracies of antiquity he writes quote
the first step of degeneration was a
subversion of law in the name of higher
values such as stability and national
security and the decline into tyranny
went unchecked by institutionalized
oversight bodies which we are now
referred to as the courts because those
bodies themselves behaved it became
involved in the rivalry fuelling the
downward spiral unquote the courts in
the media in are widely recognizes the
bulwarks of democracy but in 2000 the
Supreme Court in Bush v Gore inserted
partisan politics into the judicial
process and derailed the democratic
process while the US media has since
that ruin systematically avoided any
reporting on Syria selection dysfunction
I think that is until the recent article
in rolling stone by robert f kennedy
which has put this issue on the map but
when we place the blame only on the
media and our national oversight bodies
we are too complacent a nation also
depends on its professional and educated
elite to protect or at least speak out
about abuse of power but so few of the
professionals and academics who sit
comfortably atop the status quo have
been willing to take responsibility as
individual citizens and in the end the
question does riz rest with the
citizenry all the citizenry how far are
we going to let things go how hard are
we willing to fight for our democratic
principles and processes how meaningful
change if meaningful changes to come it
will be because something changed in us
bringing a new wave of skepticism of
hope of honest inquiry of anger and of
common purpose thank
so while we wait for representative
Conyers we are going to go to the
questions and answer period we do have
to use this microphone right here so
everybody can hear and also for c-span
so we can just step up and then we can
create a line and then our two authors
will answer them thanks so what about
putting people in jail getting people in
front of a court to testify there must
have been hundreds of people involved
this was fixed in Ohio why don't we get
some of them in jail so they can tell us
who put them up to it well I mean
there's sort of two I think levels of
corruption one is sort of the
quasi-legal corruption that happened as
in Florida with vote suppression in Ohio
that's very well documented as far as
hundreds of people being involved i
don't think that hundreds of people are
needed to subvert an electronic voting
system so i think that the numbers
involved there would probably oracle
running is talking about disparities all
over the place
and counties this that I mean it would
take hundreds of people and I can't
believe we can't get a few of them in
jail and get them saying who put them up
we first need an investigation by some
legal body yeah I mean there are people
trying to do that there are some
lawsuits and in place it's very
difficult because of who runs the state
who runs this in particular the State
Department in Ohio and and and the
courts Ohio like the US federal
government is is really in complete
control by the Republican Party so you
know it somehow takes some sort of
outside break in the system the standard
mean this is this is a very very
difficult problem very difficult for
most of the other political problems we
face in this country it's not one you
can simply legislate or vote or or use
the courts to necessarily get your way
out of probably going to require some
different sorts of measures and tactics
Greg Palast came out with a book
recently where he cited something like
three million votes were disallowed as
for some one reason or another that his
actual ballots were disallowed because
of and he claimed that these were
disproportionately african-american
minority ballots now my question is what
do you think is the overall effect of
disenfranchisement + alt possible
alteration of belts in the in the 2004
election of the you cited 10 million
discrepancy if you include
disenfranchisement like in Ohio I mean
we heard those of us who went to the
Rayburn building and and kanye's had is
hearing right after the election heard
all these examples of disenfranchisement
in Ohio I
what Palace throat about is is a
long-standing problem in u.s. voting
technologies that something about two to
three percent of votes are lost every
every election and they're lost
disproportionately in poor and minority
districts where the voting technology is
weaker where you know you put ballots in
and they somebody right score and they
fill in the the circle for Gore and they
also write his name in the right and
just to make sure that the vote is that
people understand who they're voting for
and the vote gets spit out as an over
vote so that's a long-standing problem
if the thing to be careful about though
is can't be fighting the problems of the
past and in this sense electronic voting
one of its you know marketing attributes
is that it can eliminate these lost
votes so unfortunately here we then have
a cure that's much worse than the
disease it does bring down these numbers
of laws votes but you just have no idea
who the votes are ever cast for and
there's no possibility of going back for
an audit it seems to me that what we're
seeing here is that the value of if
you're going to steal steal big you
still the executive and the Congress
ended judiciary and when you own all of
those and noting that the people want to
do is going to count yeah I think I
think that's true and in fact like
nobody looked very closely I mean that's
true on two levels it's true you know in
terms of taking everything in its term
in terms of taking the amount one of the
reasons people didn't look so close at
the 2004 election was because well he
won by three million votes you know
nobody thought that's a number that's
reasonable to challenge and nobody
looked closely at Florida because Bush
wanted so handily but you know if people
went in and did an investigation there
like they did in Ohio I would expect
that we'd find similar things
and again it it almost sounds hopeless
when you say it that way but it really
isn't quite hopeless you look around and
in fact there's aside from the points
that the Joel made there are examples
around the world of Nations and even
without even any tradition of democracy
where they've gone and they've
overturned elections and in the Ukraine
and Serbia and and the former Soviet
republic of Georgia they you know
through it through a wide variety of
techniques and measures beyond beyond
normal voting and and legislation people
have regained control over over their
nations a representative kanye's will be
here in 10 minutes just got enough ah
let me put it in the form of questions
because that's the way you want it isn't
it true that that the Democratic Party
did a survey of what happened in Ohio
and came to the conclusion that there
was no fraud isn't it true that dr. mr.
Conyers report does not say that there's
fraud in in Ohio isn't it true that when
the electoral count act was implemented
and in the House of Representatives
certain representatives from Ohio
including mr. Conyers as well as
stephanie tubbs jones sherrod Brown and
cat and Marcy Kaptur spoke none of them
said that there was fraud in Ohio isn't
that true and isn't it isn't it true
that that what the real problem is in
Ohio was the partisanship and isn't it
true that you're wasting your anti lose
track I'm going to lose track of all
these as in the truth can we take what
you've given us a fine that's fine okay
okay let's see what were they v-0 the NC
report yes the DNC report if you look
carefully at the DNC report it's
quite an interesting document they write
here from the Washington Post okay and
it quotes the fact that not what you
there was no no no let me let me please
answer okay the they did conclude that
if you look specifically at all the
allegations though I mean there are
there at their allegation substantiated
after allegation about many of the kind
of things that that I mentioned in
Clermont County and in term they also
talked extensively which we haven't
talked about just now about all the
votes oppression measures with with with
misallocated voting machines and and I
mean we we address this in the book if
you put any of these combinations of of
documented malfeasance together you
would you would conclude that in fact
the election was overturned as a result
of these things it's a the conclusions
are curiously divorced from all the
particular findings in that report what
was what was the net both of it the dnc
report also volat brings up the question
of the exit polls and its introduction
to the report it doesn't discuss them at
all within the reporter deal with that
issue that were done in Ohio were within
the Z no it's not true and let me take
these one at a time before you keep
mounting them on no that is not true it
was true that the election night what
was reported election night was within
the margin of error and that's a very
very generous margin of error there they
want to be ninety-nine point nine
ninety-nine point nine percent certain
of a result before they project the
victor so within that very generous
margin of error it was but but those
polls were not the actual survey results
those were combined with pre-election
telephone polls that have other issues
and again a very conservative measure
when you actually look at the the
details of the disparity between how
people said they voted and how and the
official results it's nearly 11
percentage point
so that is way way way beyond any margin
of error well you cannot agree but that
Hong Kong at top ski doesn't agree with
you who did the polls that eleven
percent discrepancy comes from a toss
his own report and looking at the
figures within his report is your
conclusion and it's very hard for
anybody to believe that by taking two
thousand voters who by their self
selection come and talk to the no
they're not they're not by self-select
see I don't have to they are going to
move on it's not by let me just finish
this one point though it's not at all
self selected these are random randomly
selected precincts and within those
precincts you take a random selection of
voters so these are as accurate a
polling system as you can as you can
devise there are problems with the polls
but none of none of them account for
this kind of disparity maybe before I go
into my question i'll just say just to
preface it um I I think what we're
talking about is the difference between
plausible arguments and arguments that
are actually backed by evidence and you
know in reading your book that's that's
what I found a lot of you know a lot of
these plausible the arguments that we've
heard from you know from from Warren
meta have ski and and mystery pollster
mr. Blumenthal plausible plausible
theories but plausible arguments but
there's a difference between plausible
and evidence I was impressed with what I
read here and the way I look at this
since you're basically looking at the
mathematical results looki looking at
the mathematics it seems like you put
the ball in their court again one way or
the other either you're very easily
disproven through a mathematical
analysis or know the mathematical
analysis supports what you've been doing
what what's been your reaction from
within the Vista tistic all you meant
you mentioned that the president of the
American Statistical Association and
others i mean are you beginning to see
some people saying okay admittedly yes
you you you know your arguments do make
sense the plausible arguments that
you've been fighting really aren't
working at this point where is that
going and I guess my
second question if you can arm the whole
issue over the raw data I'll make the
the pollsters Edison meant offski
haven't have not been willing to release
that I was just wondering is there any
precedent I mean in a previous election
where we looked at the raw data for
whatever reason and is there a a legal
justification for them to hold on to the
data have there been you know are there
any precedents we're basically they said
okay let's look at the raw data and that
they won't now thank you say yeah okay
they're basically two questions have we
been making progress within the various
academic and other communities and and
thus it well let's take that one first
and I think I think we are it's a slow
process the robert f kennedy jr. article
was a big break it was the first big big
break into the media the academic
disciplines like the media it's very
tough nut to crack here on a superficial
level you could look at it as a problem
of conspiracy theorists there is just
such a such a connotation and I mean it
Annunaki is it to be accused of being a
conspiracy theorist is enough to get you
drummed out of either the journalism
core or or any any political science or
public opinion research department in
the nation nobody who gets called a
conspiracy theorist has any chance of
getting an academic position I come from
outside the field so I'm a little bit
safer on this count but that is a
tremendously well established biased so
it's a it's a difficult thing to break
through the personal response has been
pretty good it's hard to get into the
journals for a lot of reasons because
you have to take on so many different
issues at one time that was the reason
for writing this book rather than rather
than just trying to do it one article at
a time for example you know I write the
article and then they say well the
how come the pre-election polls then
don't that the pre-election polls
basically support it they were they
basically did not differ that far from
the official count and so that's a whole
nother set of issues we have a whole
chapter on the problem with the public
opinion the telephone poles and why they
would be so far off but it's very hard
to academics it's very narrow very
narrow kind kinds of arguments you have
to make and to take on so many
assumptions at what time it's very
difficult basically what political
scientists and public opinion
researchers do is they look at official
results and then they come up with
explanations for why that is if you take
away that official count as being a
being gospel as being a number you can
really count on and being very solid
most of these people most of everything
they've done is is then held up to
question so so it's a it's a real
challenge in those communities but i
think we are making progress in all of
it i forgot the second question by now
so i'll just make it a brief comment on
the second question i'm the one in the
meta ski report one of the interesting
findings was that in small town and
rural precincts which counted paper
ballots which had hand mark paper
ballots there is no discrepancy between
the exit polls in the official count
there was a discrepancy however between
machines and the exit polls and it's
this question of the data which is
available in meta ski and the consortium
consortium habit of precinct by precinct
and if that data was publicly available
one would be able to look at a precinct
look at what type of voting machine that
precinct used and then compare the size
of the exit poll discrepancy so you'd
have a sort of very I think a very good
way to verify whether there was a
problem with the voting machines that
were being used in 2004 that material
for a number of reasons was not
forthcoming but I think that would be
the place to start if there was to be a
formal investigation and his
representative conyers
well I left the house of representatives
were still in session but there was no
way I was going to miss Freeman and look
lifeless is that correct who have made
such a important contribution to the
growing re-examination of what went
wrong in Ohio and believe me I have
never seen so many friends so many
Democrats so many liberals rolled on
this question the fury of the people in
Columbus when we went there with i think
was ten eleven members of Congress i
remember very specifically Jerry Nadler
was there and Maxine Waters flew all the
way in on a red-eye from Los Angeles to
be there and of course we had a number
of Ohio members there but the fury of
the people who were so angry still very
very upset about the things that happen
not only on Election Day but before
Election Day and I had never encountered
that kind of emotion in terms of of an
election issue that had been closed down
and so what our two authors are doing
here today is absolutely
critical this case will not be shut down
because a number of people got it wrong
and to me of each development each
release of new material bills on all the
materials that are coming out now we've
got we've got a nice little set of
people all doing their own thing that
come to the same conclusion that that
this was not a fair election that the
outcome was was not one that anyone
could accept who made an impartial
evaluation of how the election was set
up and then of course you have the the
eminent Secretary of State who was a
work of art he's worth a book all by
himself I mean we ought to really go
back and look at some of some of the
zany things he did all the time as the
co-chairman of the bush reelection
campaign for ohio and i think i think
the citizens will keep that in mind on
the first tuesday in november in the
race that he's running which he is still
the Secretary of State for his own
election for governor so what do you
make of that well all of these things
all of these things add up to all the
curious activities of our election
process in America the first thing that
and one of the last things I want to see
is that it's not like we're not used to
screwed up elections in America this was
not something that was inconceivable and
we're shot people have been doing bad
things illegal things in elections for a
long time what we're trying to do is to
slow down if not put a halt to the
things that diminish the democratic
process in terms of choosing who governs
and to me Ohio was in its own way and I
think we made some comparisons about
Florida first and then Ohio next up but
it was stunning and the evidence keeps
piling up it's not only a historical
interest that I think brings most of us
you but it's the fact that we've got to
learn how to stop this from continuing
because it's been my experience that
once you get pretty good at breaking the
law in one area and you continue to get
away with it you keep getting a little
bit better every time you don't get
worse you get a little more clever and
so this is a huge challenge facing more
than a dozen states out here I mean Ohio
and Florida were just you know the
stunning first place examples but there
there are a lot of other places that I
need examination so we're not giving
them a pass and so what we're doing is
trying to get ready for the next
election only four months from now and
another presidential election in 08
and I think this book has come out at
the right time right after Kennedy's
rolling stone article which was I
thought excellent another whole
perspective but more and more people
that are looking at this are realizing
that this is a story that has yet to be
fully told to more and more people and
that's and that's why I came out of the
Congress with votes of plenty going on
tonight to be here with you and to say
thank you Freeman and Blythe let's give
them a real round of applause for what
they have done this it's so critical
that we learned that a democracy is run
by us we the people are the only ones
between an imperial government and
that's what we're trying to stop and so
I'm so happy that I'm on the Judiciary
Committee where voting rights is our
current activity we're trying to correct
vote election irregularities which are
are so numerous and so we've got a big
feel in front of us and it's being made
more complicated as more and more
technology is introduced and the dye
bowls and the other companies are all in
there almost displacing election workers
as they used to be the ones that ran
things well now a person comes in and
says look I can get this thing
straightened out for you and you won't
have to be here recounting half the
night
just stand back over here and with a few
little thing one person can now throw a
major election and so we we have to be
very sensitive to that I'm so pleased
that all of us came out tonight I only
hope that there's something I can do to
help this book get on the bestseller
list it should be in every library of
every critical American there should be
more examinations of what went wrong in
Ohio coming out in the near past I close
on this note we took I guess Hayes
Tilden was the worst election
presidential election that was it was
pretty bad but it was kind of old style
and yet the Congress passed a law the
next year saying for the first time that
a state's electoral ballots could be
counted recounted and examined if there
were people in the Congress that felt
that ought to happen unfortunately thank
God for Senator Barbara Boxer of
California who stood up on the Senate
and said this is enough I'm going to
join with stephanie tubbs jones and
we're going to challenge the electoral
count in ohio and we we did it in in a
fashion but we were politically
outmaneuvered most people and the
Congress were persuaded that there were
some problems John but please let's not
get overheated this thing we have
problems in all elections but now we
have the evidence coming in
and we're not going to let this thing go
we're not going to let Florida go we
have a help America Vote Act which they
ignored in the breach with provisional
ballot II but we had a we have another
voter rights act built on the Ohio
experiences that hasn't even had a
single hearing that's that's how tight
this thing is run that's how sinister
the whole thing is and you know
sometimes conspirators don't have to
meet in a plan to you do this and I'll
take that and will they all know what
they've got to do we've got pictures of
a former Chief Justice of the United
States who as a lawyer without they're
harassing voters himself in person with
his pictures it was all documented and
and that's become a way of life so what
what you've done for us gentlemen is a
very important contribution I'm proud to
be with you tonight but more than that
i'm happy that you could bring this many
people out and you should really give
yourselves a hand for being here and
thank you very much
do yall winter do you all want to react
to it representative condors heads
before i do my okay mmm using a couple
of points i'm i grew up in jacksonville
florida duval county we're in the you
know 2,000 election all the old machines
those that were subject to jamming and
causing all those weird chads and such
stuff all the old machines were shipped
over to the west side of town where I
grew up which had a lot more has a lot
more minorities than not so it's set up
votes not being counted in in in two
thousand because the machine gets jammed
many long lines etc so that the history
was there I think that you no matter
what happens it well if it turns out and
I you know that the points can be made
and people will it will end up people
will just become more cynical about the
electoral process and people will stay
home instead of voting because well
obviously it doesn't matter anyway and I
think it is part of that conspiracy if
there is a conspiracy to get people just
not to vote I mean in other words
there's well on our way I feel like the
the kid in the grapes of wrath you know
the words whose farm is being shut down
and told that you know the guy driving
the tractor to wreck is Shaq isn't to
blame and the bankers not to blame and
the state people aren't to blame so he's
in the kids says you know well who do we
shoot I'm not advocating it I'm just
making a reference to fine American
literature
and you know I hope that you all have
some you know proposals you know the the
League of Women Voters is soo springs to
mind for being you know civic minded and
part of the you know the goo goo good
government people but you know they get
ran out of doing the election debates
and I just hope that they were a similar
body can somehow you know the words come
ahead or do you all have some other
solutions
well I'd like to if if the leadership in
the Congress changes after the first
tuesday in november we need to hold
meetings I'm thinking of a lot of things
that we ought to do it's a long list to
believe me over after six or eight years
so we've got to keep reexamining this
we've got to enact some legislation that
picks up on the the points that are
missing here that have never been
considered in the Congress and we've got
to give people hope I mean there are a
lot of people now not a lot but there
are people who are beginning to wonder
they know that voting is important but
they're wondering if their vote will be
counted or will they get swindled out of
it some way and and I think that that
morale factor is very important because
as has been said it's it's not really
this isn't like a basketball game in who
won and who lost this is about the
fabric of the most important single
right that we all possess in a
democratic society and so there will be
lots of things to do you can give us a
few ideas anybody that wants to but
we'll be holding public meetings and
being asked and asking you to put up go
on our website or blog us or meet with
us in in the capital and and let's get
this thing on the road remember between
now and O's and in November of 06 is a
is a critical critical time if a person
was a wasn't going to vote much I'd say
well please vote this year
because this is the time that we're
going to make a change and if we don't
make the change will be in the same
place will be coming out to some other
authors a wonderful book and will be
will have a new state and be a new set
of problems to really change this and
your questions the greatest one is what
do we do well what we do is get out and
vote and get as many people out to vote
as we can that's the very first thing we
do and then we can get all of our
experts together and talk to each other
about the legislative and other
activities at the federal and state
level that we would be able to employ to
make the system better that's all we're
trying to do I'd like to just add a
little something to that too and that's
there's this to kind of levels to that
question one is voting is important and
it's still important and you don't we
don't we can't have complete confidence
in the count but many places hopefully
most places the counts are reliable you
can always vote absentee well most
places you can vote absentee as a as an
alternative to electronic voting but
voting is just the is just one out of
many possible civic measures that people
can take and if voting is all people do
in a democracy a democracy really won't
function least of all now there are many
kinds of tasks of verification that can
be performed and and other activities
such as they're being done in emerging
democracies in the Ukraine for example
you know people want to know about the
solution but but part of it is a big
part of acknowledging the problem I mean
unless people are really acknowledging
and have some awareness about what's
what the current state of democracy is
in this country then there's little
motivation to do all those things so so
at least in in our opinion of
the first step is really saying what
where we at and and getting people to
know it it's just a tiny fraction of
people that have any awareness of the
the extent of this story so we're trying
to get the word out about that and and
once that word is out there are there
are a wide variety of measures that can
be drawn upon to try to try to make some
meaningful change okay so the three
people who are in line if you could just
give us your questions and then answer
them in a group and then we're going to
go to the signing I appropriately enough
i'm following the gentleman from Florida
as I grew up in Ohio and as congressman
Conyers mentioned Secretary of State Ken
Blackwell is running for governor of
ohio this year and still controls the
electoral machine there are you aware of
any safeguards that have been the local
voters or Democrats in Ohio have been
able to put in place to ensure that this
gubernatorial election might be somewhat
transparent
yeah I'm actually sorry that
representative Conyers left because
first of all it's easy for me to agree
with your you know what you're
suspecting I'm so I'm on that side but
on the other hand I have to agree with
the gentleman who's asking for a little
bit more evidence some affidavits some
people on the inside I mean certainly
there are a few people that are required
but usually you can crack some corporate
crime and things like that so do you
have a strategy maybe it's not your your
area but but somebody who is familiar
with prosecute prosecutorial um you know
techniques should be included in this
type of thing and I don't know what is
the problem with the Democrats and with
the labor unions and so forth because
there's a substantial group of people
whose interests are immediately affected
by this if you can't get elected it's
it's absurd so I don't understand that
part of it well it seems like um thank
you for documenting this evidence and
because they haven't released the
results of their exit polls and he's a
private group of companies I suspect
they'll never let that mistake happen
again they're going to fix the next
round of exit polls to match up with the
votes that they've fixed so is there
anything we can do could a public entity
or a number of volunteers somehow
achieve what the exit polls by the
private companies have achieved in the
past if you think that might be possible
or that's my question
just a point on the current Ohio
election for governor I know that you
know everybody's watching ohio very
carefully and it's interesting that
blackwell is sort of continuing what he
started with 2004 and his current race
for governor for example he ruled that
people who are collecting signatures
voter registration signatures it used to
be that individuals would collect them
they'd you know sign them as they were
valid voter who was collecting the
signatures then they'd be turned in he
ruled that the individual person
collecting the votes has to go to the
courthouse individually and file the
votes that they collected so that
there's no way to sort of centralize the
system and use volunteers to get a lot
of people registered and then the other
thing is what's specifically one court
thing that could specifically be done is
that if there was a say a house
judiciary committee that had powers
pinna it could subpoena the records from
the the consortium that did the exit
polls and that would be one way to look
to see if there were specific precincts
where there was a huge discrepancy
between the vote and the official count
of what kind of voting technology was
used there and i know that steve has
things to say on a couple of these
things too and I'll turn it over to him
as far as people coming well there were
a few points Ohio Ohio there are people
trying to do things but I want to be too
optimistic about Ohio 2006 there was a
election in ohio in 2005 that produced
some astounding results there were an
exit polls done but measures which were
and some of which had to do with voting
systems that had overwhelming popular
support that failed at the pole so so
ohio was a very difficult situation as
far as people coming forward there but
there are people trying to do things
that I you know I that they may they may
be successful including a lot of
lawsuits people coming forward to happen
people come forward there's a lot of
affidavits many of which were collected
by the Conyers committee people of
tested to astounding things a serious
criminal conduct I mean the things that
are already documented you know not even
the allegations or are you know just so
much more severe than things that got
Nixon booted from office I mean these
are people say well move on I mean the
people Clinton was impeached for
comparatively nothing and and like I
said Nixon was removed from well chase
from office for for much less more
people may be coming forward here you
have to look at where were the
incentives have been but even even there
some people have come forward about with
affidavits about electronic voting and
there may be much more now that now that
a prominent person robert f kennedy jr.
as has taken the lead on this the exit
polls in the future yes one of the
improvements for the exit polls in the
coming election is that they are not
going to release early results even to
their own clients even to the media so
so that is to get rid of the possibility
of leaks as there were in this past
election in fact big part of the reason
we even know about the exit poll
discrepancy in this past election was
because what was because partly leaks to
bloggers and it was also because a
technical glitch prevented them from
updating the screens on CNN it on
election night the but there i'm part of
a group that is proposing an independent
exit poll we're seeking funding for it
right now and this would be one with
full transparency and open public data
available specifically designed to do
election verification and there are many
precedents for this this is done around
the world and it's sponsored by the US
government in fact perhaps the best
ideas on how to how to take back a
democracy come from the US State
Department they were the ones who took
the lead in in in funding exit polls in
the Ukraine and
and and the Soviet republic of Georgia
organizing mass protests as soon as that
discrepancy was known and and getting
the word out to to various media
channels and as we all know that those
efforts there were successful so there's
a group in based in Ohio us count votes
which I've done some papers with and and
for that has published a few things on
what voters and what candidates and what
parties can do and the list is the list
is pretty impressive and and lengthy and
I I would advise people to to look at
that to look at that website yes and in
the book we have further readings and we
mention that and some other other
sources okay before everybody jumps up
and rushes I would like to thank both
Steven and Joel for coming out tonight I
would like to thank absolutely this book
is a phenomenal read and I can't
recommend it enough i would like to also
thank representative Conyers for taking
the time to come out and but support
this book and come out to tonight's
event there are some various groups here
that will be talking to people if you
when you stand up